[Musik]
hinter mikas luft klassiker steckt
simple physik und eine reihe günstiger
zutaten
gespart
so schnell kann schokolade günstig
werden sebastian lege deckt das
alpenmilch märchen auf und zeigt welche
milka schokolade die teuerste ist
herzlich willkommen in meiner tricks
höhle die alm romantik ist vorbei und
für klassische schokolade benötigen wir
kakaobutter
cacau masse
und zucker in
milka schokolade kommt noch viel viel
mehr rein
kakaobutter ist mit abstand die teuerste
zutat in einer schokolade darum wird sie
bei milka so sparsam wie möglich
eingesetzt für geschmack sorgen andere
zutaten
vanille aroma
endgültiges kakaopulver
haselnuss passte
und jetzt kommen gleich die alten erst
mal süß molkepulver
und jetzt ist es soweit
magermilchpulver aus den alpen nach mit
jedem level sprich geld
weg und schon wieder geld gespart und
wieder geld gespart ach ist das schön so
schnell kann schokolade günstig werden
die milch wird also erst einmal zu
pulver verarbeitet bevor sie in die
schokolade kommt von all den gesunden
inhaltsstoffen echter held milch bleibt
da nur wenig übrig und die hauptzutat
ist ohnehin eine ganz andere
[Musik]
ja das muss jetzt rühren rühren rühren
rühren rühren rühren rühren rühren
rühren weil es ja schön knacken
normalerweise braucht man dafür eine
keusche da
rotiert ein rührlöffel über mehrere
stunden manchmal sogar mehrere tage umso
länger umso besser umso schöner der
schmelz auf der zunge ich gehe draußen
kurz die lila kuh wird dann bis gleich
ich hab da noch was vergessen
stundenlang wir brauchen wir doch gar
nicht haben doch suizid ihn mein gott
rain damit legitim ist ein emulator mit
seiner hilfe mischen sich fett und
wasser ohne langes rühren
die industrie setzt auf künstlich
hergestelltes aus soja
das ganze muss ich noch mal zehn minuten
rühren und dann ist unsere alpenmilch
schokolade fertig
fix zusammengerührt mit jeder menge
günstiger industrie zutaten doch der
erfolg beweist der alpenmilch trick
funktioniert
[Musik]
deshalb nehmen sich viele konkurrenten
an milka ein beispiel und verkaufen
ebenfalls helfen milchschokolade in der
angeblich ganz viel gute alpenmilch
steckt
[Musik]
seit vielen jahren schon nimmt milka
deshalb regelmäßig neue produkte und
geschmacksrichtungen ins programm um
sich weiter von der konkurrenz zu
unterscheiden
ein beliebtes beispiel oft schokolade
[Musik]
haben sie sich schon mal gefragt wie
luft schokolade hergestellt wird die
antwort kommt jetzt eine vakuum glocke
eine pumpe und flüssigen stickstoff zum
kühlen mehr braucht der
produktentwickler nicht
safety first
der trick sebastian will die
luftbläschen nicht in die warme
schokolade hineinpumpen sondern dafür
sorgen dass sie praktisch von selbst
entstehen
kleine bläschen sie kommen
sie steigt und steigt und steigt und
steigt
so wie omega
durch den unterdruck dehnt sich die luft
im inneren der schokolade aus nach dem
aushärten bleiben jede menge kleine
bläschen zurück luftbläschen zu
luftbläschen
so kann man schokolade aufpumpen ein
bisschen druck die schokolade kommt nach
oben sie wird kalt und wir denken was
für ein luftiges
schokoladige erlebnis mit ganz viel
mager milch
milch im fall von luft schokolade sorgt
simple physik dafür dass eine neue sorte
entsteht
[Musik]
bei den meisten anderen varianten im
milka sortiment selbst model s auf neue
meist ausgefallene zutaten
auf den ersten blick sind alle
schokoladen gleich groß und kosten auch
alle dasselbe 1 euro 15 pro tafel
doch bei genauerem hinsehen wird klar
die tafeln sind eben nicht gleich groß
ihr gewicht unterscheidet sich und zwar
beträchtlich
und so verdient mehr kam mit seinem
neuen geschmacksrichtungen bis zu 20
prozent mehr ohne dass verbraucher etwas
davon mitbekommen
[Musik]
96 der bundesbürger kennen die marke und
ihr zentrales werbeversprechen die
alpenmilch
400 prozent alpenmilch
die gute ein mensch macht unsere
schokolade so zart sehen sie schon das
alpenpanorama und hören sie die kugel
leuten schöner
da hat man doch das gefühl von
hochwertigen zutaten in diesem produkt
sebastian lege will dem geheimnis der
alpenmilch auf die spur kommen und reist
mitten in die alpen nach bayern ramsau
die 1500 meter über dem meeresspiegel
was für ein alpenpanorama und
hier soll es die echte alpenmilch geben
die später in der milka schokolade
landet bin ich mal gespannt
auf dem layenhof wird echte alb milch
hergestellt kurz nach sechs ist zeit zum
melken bei 1 bauer miliz
morgen
war früher für die gute alte milch
[Gelächter]
kurkuma der wartet schon der warte auf
die gute alte mühle zehn liter braucht
der kleine davon jeden tag damit er groß
und stark wird
jetzt geht darauf freue ich mich was ist
das schön hier insgesamt zwölf kühe
stehen hier auf der weide und wenn es
zeit zum melken ist kommen sie alle brav
von alleine in den stall
so mittels futter
frisches heu von den umliegenden
bergwiesen das bekommen die tiere hier
jeden tag nicht zum sattwerden sondern
mehr damit ihnen beim herum stehen nicht
langweilig wird jeden morgen vor
sonnenaufgang legt allen bauer mit
seinen kühen die melkmaschine an ohne
urlaub ohne wochenende
365 tage im jahr und was gibt so eine
kuh im schnitt
im schnitt
18 sektor ist ja eigentlich nicht zu der
industrie meti sonst überall das in der
hochleistungs tür herein mit den können
wir mit den hochleistungs können wir
leider nicht mithalten aber ist leider
die führung wieder super qualität diese
milch enthält viel fett mit gesunden
omega-3-fettsäuren die kühe von michi
fonds sind traditionelle besonders
widerstandsfähige rassen
[Applaus]
jetzt lassen wir die kühe auf die weide
damit würde das gute frische gras
fressen können und erwarten das würde zu
merken gekommen sein wir sagen konnten
sie daraus
nur wenn schnee liegt bleiben die kühe
im stall um die weide zu schonen wann
immer es das wetter zulässt verbringen
die tiere ihre tage von früh bis spät
draußen an der frischen luft
[Musik]
anders als die milch wie sonst trinke ja
so
grausige noten die schmeckt komplexer
dies ist ein bisschen breiter im
geschmack und
vollmundig echt lecker mein gott
milch schmeckt so lecker weil die tiere
besonderes futter bekommen sie fressen
nur das gras von der eigenen weide
hochleistungskühe bekommen dagegen oft
mais und soja aus übersee verfüttert auf
den 40 hektar weideland von michi fonds
wächst das futter für gerade mal zwölf
kühe nachhaltiger als hier kann man
milch nicht produzieren
meint sie die genossenschaft verkauft
die milch an milka
führt sie nie verkaufen
die tut es sicherlich nicht so guten
alten milch ist ein ganz besonderes
lebensmittel gerade einmal fünf prozent
der deutschen milchproduktion stammen
von den almen in den alpen
[Musik]
da würde ich mich wohlfühle haarig
bleibt ja schön
nähten platzt
was sie entsteht wird zum großen teil
als bergbauern milch oder rohmilch
direktverkauf mit einem schönen
preisaufschlag
[Musik]
doch woher kommt all die alpenmilch die
massenhafte milka schokolade steckt
jeder tropfen nicht in unserer milka
alpenmilch schokolade
stammt von 65 in
butter
[Musik]
doch wo sich diese höfe mit gerade
einmal 60 kühen befinden das verrät die
werbung nicht wir wollen es genauer
wissen und bitten by milka und bei der
konzernmutter model s um ein interview
vergeblich schriftlich teilte man uns
mit die milch stamme von kleinen
bauernhöfen die innerhalb eines 100
kilometer radius in den alpen liegen an
anderer stelle heißt es die milch stamme
auch aus dem alpenvorland
das problem daran ist das wort
alpenmilch ist gesetzlich überhaupt
nicht geregelt im schlimmsten fall
könnte die kuh in der region der alpen
die ganze zeit im stall gestanden haben
und diese schöne region überhaupt nicht
gesehen haben und es dürfte trotzdem als
alten mich verkauft werden hier zählt
nur der werbeeffekt den verbrauchern ein
schönes bild vermittelt wenn euch unsere
videos gefallen und ihr nicht genug
kriegen könnt von unserem besser ist
dann gibt es hier noch mehr videos und
las amazon abonnieren -button da ich
würde mich freuen bis bald